you know I can just picture how the
board meeting at Sony went probably want
something like this if someone asks you
if you want to milk a franchise that we
have control of you say yes so this news
came out of flipping nowhere
apparently Jason Reitman is going to
begin work on another Ghostbusters film
which is going to be tied to the
original two Ghostbusters films that his
dad directed and I really don't know how
to feel about this so a little bit of
background the original Ghostbusters is
my favorite movie of all times
I don't like Ghostbusters to like really
at all
I'm fairly indifferent to the what was
it 2016 Ghostbusters film that came out
I thought it was okay could have been a
lot worse there were some things that
worked it was unnecessary I didn't hate
it though I I dislike goes +2 more than
I dislike that but really for as much as
I love Ghostbusters my love of it
basically goes as far as the first film
and maybe about 20 episodes of the Real
Ghostbusters which I have the entire box
set of an adore but honestly there's
only there's only about maybe two dozen
episodes out of the hot over a hundred
in there that I'd like I adore so as
much as I love this thing I will also be
very upfront that Ghostbusters hasn't
been great
in a while at least none of the things
that I've taken it I know it's had a
couple of comic books and whatnot I've
I've never gotten around to checking out
those but this and and part of the thing
that's like affecting my not knowing how
to think about this is actually did a
video not all that long ago talking
about how I actually don't think it
would be the worst idea in the world to
do a sequel to the last Ghostbusters
movie with the female cast because while
that movie had a fair number of problems
with it and to be clear the fact that it
was all woman was not the problem with
the film it did have a fair number of
other problems though and I I kind of
wanted to see them try again and see if
they could refine it and do it better
now that's very obviously not going to
happen and like I'm gonna be nervous
about this for the same reason I'm gonna
be nervous about anything I love that's
been dormant for a while being picked up
again like is this gonna be anything
other than just an attempt to attempt to
milk the property now it probably does
help at least a little bit that it's
being directed by Jason Reitman instead
of Ivan Reitman because Ivan Reitman
hasn't really done a really good movie
in a while so that's not bad news we
have at this point we have no idea if
any of the cast from the original are
going to be involved in any way shape or
form it's possible but nobody's signed
on yet right now it's only him now as
far as jason reitman himself goes he's a
pretty good director he's made some
pretty good movies that said he hasn't
really dabbled in this kind of movie yet
and I have to wonder if he's trying to
sort of shore up his clout a little bit
because I'm his first movie was thank
you for smoking which was quite good and
his next two movies got you know Oscar
nominations and wins cuz he did you know
and he did up in the air um the things
he deeds done since then he did
young adult and Tully with Charlize
Theron's and the front-runner with Hugh
Jackman uh none of which really kind of
did much for people they bomb or tank at
least not as far as I know but they were
the kind of movies that were never gonna
be massive box-office hit so they kind
of needed to be critical darlings which
is what thank you for smoking Juno and
up in the air all world and I have to
wonder since he's going a little while
now on movies that were basically pretty
good and weren't making massive returns
if that puts him in a position where he
it's it's in his career best interest to
well to make something that's more or
less guaranteed to make its money back
now I say guaranteed obviously just
slapping the ass busters name on
anything doesn't work the last one
didn't really wanna teen make the money
that they were planning on and for the
man once you factor in the marketing
push which we won't ever know the budget
on it probably lost them at least a
little bit I broke even at best so I I
don't want to imply that just slapping
that name means it makes money but you
know it certainly helps it makes it a
lot more likely that it's going to do
well because it's got that name
recognition and everything else I
suppose whether or not I ever decide if
this is a good idea is gonna have a lot
to do with what what the concept is
what's the story
colonel what's the what's the main
thrust of it are we getting any of the
original cast back are they the main
characters is this passing of the torch
and I don't necessarily have an inherent
preference for which of these to do I
just think I'll have a better sense of
what I should think once I know what it
is and what the situation is that we're
dealing with here and it's
I'm just kind of tired I think I I think
I was really ready to at least for
myself to put Ghostbusters to bed for a
while you know even though as I said I
would have been I was very much open to
to a sequel to the to the all-female
Ghostbusters just to see if they could
do it better and and you know take the
bits that worked and do more with them
but if they weren't gonna do that I was
kind of like okay well you know you had
something that went for a while a hard
reboot it didn't work let's leave it be
but then we are in an era where movie
studios thrive on franchises I mean that
is how they keep everybody happy it's
how well theoretically is how to keep
audience is heavy it's really how they
keep shareholders happy because you know
and executives because when you have a
franchise you can be planning your next
two three four five years worth of
movies in advance because you're
planning the continuations of that
franchise and statistically speaking you
having a franchise is generally good for
the box-office if it is a well-liked
franchise but I I don't I don't need
another ghostbusters and I'd like
speaking personally I don't need them to
quote-unquote fix the previous one by
giving me the Ghostbusters sequel that
maybe they should have done instead of
doing the reboot because I will grant
well I believe ER and I did a video on
it back in the day I will absolutely
great a big part of the problem with
that ghostbusters certainly for me was
the fact that it was a reboot instead of
a continuation because there really was
no reason that it shouldn't have been a
continuation so I would have always
preferred if that had been the case but
that doesn't mean that I want them to
take a do-over there are some that yes
there are some fans we kind of feel that
like I didn't like the movie that you
want go back and try again
and I kind of I guess I the thing is I
just get tired of the property that way
and also it it's really presumptuous
because if if this succeeds you know it
just tells Sony and other studios that
they could just keep hitting the reset
button over and over and over again it
will keep showing up until they until
they get it right to our satisfaction I
mean there's gonna be another Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movie reboot again
cuz they'll just keep hitting the reset
as long as we keep going ah yeah I don't
know I don't know about this whole thing
it's just it's just a thing that's gonna
happen and look Jason Reitman is a
talented guy he can make pretty good
stuff and you know I think that there's
there's potential and it sure but I
can't get excited like I don't know if
other fans are at this news are gonna be
jumping up and down in the street and
going like whoo but we don't let things
just be done anymore and normally the
reboot would have been taken as oh okay
you know we weren't really in a position
where we thought we could do a decent
continuation we try to reboot it didn't
work let's move on to something else no
they're just gonna keep hacking away at
it and I kind of don't want them to
there you go ghostbusters more of them
potentially we'll see what happens uh
what do you think about this whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff to do
cuz there's buttons and links including
one to the patreon if you want to
support me that way every little bit
does help there's also my p.o box
address whole bunch of other links to
check out besides give them a look if
you feel like it if you
that is okay because at the end of the
day you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]